So there's an on-line petition
to get the Cincinnati Bengals
to change their name
to the Cincinnati Harambes
after the Cincinnati Zoo gorilla
famous for... well, you know
that thing
that we all got upset about.
That's the gorilla that made us
forget all about Cecil the lion.
The Change.org petition
is so close
to getting the 25,000 signatures
it needs
to get someone
from the Bengals organization
to glance briefly at it before
throwing it in the garbage.
Comedians, a beloved Internet
martyr like Harambe deserves
to have more than just
a football team named after him.
What are some other things
that should be renamed
in honor of Harambe?
-Steve.
-Denny's Moons Over Harambe.
-Yeah.
-(laughter)
Yeah.
-Those are...
-Grand slam.
-Uh, Emily.
-That Cranberries song
where she's like...
♪ Harambe, Harambe
♪ Harambe,
ay-uh, ay-uh, ay-uh. ♪
I'm gonna give you
an extra hundred points...
-(applause and cheering)
-Yes! -...for committing
to the Dolores O'Riordan cackle.
Kurt Braunohler.
Uh, they should have renamed
that three-year-old so he never
forgets what he (bleep) did.